the investigation was not about the
president Jim Comey told the president
that three times in their meetings as
that never has been the center of the
investigation nor is the role the
special counsel to go try to get an
indictment of the president it is his
role was very clear to see if there's
any criminal activity among the campaign
I want to know what the basis is for
that statement by Rudy Giuliani and
whether it was just a fan view by one of
the attorneys with the special counsel
or whether it was a pronouncement by the
special counsel himself well the break
news today Rudy Giuliani telling our own
Fox News John Roberts that that the
special counsel will follow DOJ guidance
that the president cannot be indicted
according to Giuliani Muller has no
choice and they're obviously pushing for
this to come to a conclusion what does
this all mean and let's look at what the
Senate put out the Senate Intelligence
Committee and Judiciary Committee today
let's bring in our panel here in New
York former White House press secretary
Ari Fleischer Caitlin Huey Byrnes
national political reporter for Real
Clear Politics and Bill McGurn
mainstream columnist for The Wall Street
Journal okay Ari your take on the news
about Giuliani and what was said today
well it's significant but I wanted to
say the president's home free so long as
there is a special council investigating
no president is home free and neither is
the staff or the people who worked on
the campaign we have to wait for Bob
Muller and only then our people home
free so it is significant because if
Rudy Giuliani is right and I think I'd
like to hear this also from the
Department of Justice and reinforcing
what Giuliani said then it's a
significant sigh of relief in the legal
sense but as we all know from what Bill
Clinton went through this is a political
exercise in addition to a legal exercise
the real jeopardy also becomes Congress
and the American people if the American
people think crimes were committed it
will hurt Republicans and elections that
hurt the president in a real act so a
lot more needs to be said and having
said all that I still see no evidence of
collusion I don't think there's been
collusion from the start and
particularly the most pernicious which
would have been any involvement from the
Trump people and hacking Hillary or
Podesta's emails and disseminating them
which is what this was all about I mean
the other development was at the Bob
Muller
subpoenaed the social media director for
Roger stone today and we also had the
release of some Senate documents put it
in perspective for scale right well the
Senate documents really confirmed what
the intelligence community said which is
that Russia meddled in the election to
help Donald Trump and now that's
different from the house assessment the
house assessment of course the president
was cheering on but we've seen how
different those committees have operated
wasn't like we tried to straighten that
out about you know the difference in the
committee's saying that they were
looking at a specific area but go ahead
sure so I think the bigger point here
though is that the Muller investigation
continues the president it's hanging
over his administration certainly and he
has expressed frustrations with that I
am interested to see though how the
public starts to react the longer that
this goes on you have seen in polling a
slight dip in people's perceptions of
the investigation you've seen
Republicans by a large margin really
opposed that and you've seen candidates
running for office on the Republican
ticket evoking the president's language
that this is a witch-hunt
so you know the president reshuffled his
legal team because he didn't think that
he was getting the the best advice and
he wanted to have a more combative
nature with the special counsel and so
we'll see kind of how Giuliani handles
this in this new space bill mutant yeah
I I think was a good day for two reasons
one is I think it's good that the
committee's release their findings
because I think at the root of our
system is political accountability not
criminal liability but political
accountability and what the American
people need is to know what happened and
the longer we go on the more questions
we have about our intelligence community
and so forth and it seems the less
evidence there is about Donald Trump so
that's that's one side the other thing I
think mr. Giuliani's the comments could
think about what that says the special
prosecutor who ostensibly works for the
Justice Department is going to follow
Justice Department guidelines and that's
a news story I find it incredible I mean
I think the proper venue for most of
this is Congress and it's amazing to me
that Congress has been stonewalled in
men in its pursuit of many of the
documents and it's taken a backseat
we've kind of you know we've kind of
looked to criminalize political behavior
when the first accountability to should
be to the American people through their
elected representatives there's a lot we
don't know about the start of the
investigation and there's a lot that
just does not add up with that I mean
there's a lot of people looking at it
but Capitol Hill hasn't come to that
conclusion either no and you know to
quote Charles Krauthammer this has been
one of the greatest issues we've ever
seen where it's all smoke and no fire
and this is what we keep chasing and
this is why I keep coming back to the
core issue did anybody and the Trump
campaign work with Russia to hack
Hillary or Podesta's emails or work with
WikiLeaks to disseminate them the answer
is no and nobody at in two years almost
three years it's gonna with any evidence
to support either of those if the answer
is no what are we doing where is this
going we're inviting people for
financial fraud and other things having
nothing to do with the president fine it
has nothing to do with the president
anything come from in your assessment of
that transcript that 2500 pages from the
Trump Tower struck you that Donald Trump
jr. didn't know whether his dad knew or
not what well the interest in this
meeting of course is because of the
question of collusion right whether
Trump Associates were amenable or open
receptive to any help from Russian
agents and what we don't know is what
Donald Trump jr. knew or didn't know I
thought it was interesting how he said
that he didn't really talk to his father
about it but he also said in very and in
various exchanges that he didn't know or
couldn't recall and so I think this
provides a more detailed assessment of
that meeting but still I think there are
a lot of questions I think the broader
question of course is when when will
this wrap up and what will come of it
you've had lots of indictments on
Russian meddling of course that the
administration has acted on but on the
issue of collusion you do have a lot of
people asking when is this going to be
answer final word on this I want to do a
round on North Korea
yeah well you know my saying is special
councils corrupt independent councils
corrupt absolutely there's a reason
we're at this stage and we're finding no
evidence and we're going on so to be
nice if we do get to a conclusion I
agree with Caitlin I think also a lot of
people are getting tired but they're not
getting tired because of the search
they're getting tired that they're not
seeing as Ari says any hard evidence we
keep sort of spinning our wheels the
pages today are sort of interesting they
give a lot more detail and granularity
but we knew from Donald Trump juniors
email what he went to this meeting to
see and so forth so I'm not sure
materially it adds and what we don't
know what we really don't know is why
and when the FBI launched the
investigation we know what they say but
we're not yet clear on why they in the
vacuum of all this as Kaylin mentioned
the president's poll numbers are going
up yeah right well they haven't found a
fitness on the main the main attack
against him so you know you would expect
that plus if the economy is getting
better why wouldn't it go up okay North
Korea it looks like it's you know touch
and go whether this summits happening or
not your thoughts you've been around the
block with the North Koreans they don't
really you know keep up with promises
all the time I've been a cynic all along
on this day taunt with North Korea
because I've lived through it before
I've seen North Korea lie deceive say
that they'll stop enrichment of uranium
only to start enriched and start
developing plutonium to pursue a nuclear
weapon they say we got rid of our
nuclear weapons but then they have 50
more they've got rid of ten they kept 50
this is North Korea so I think President
Trump should proceed with the military
drill with South Korea do not back down
you back down one inch to the North
Koreans it will roll all over you be
tough be firm and I expect if the summit
goes on be tough be firm there but the
real issue is going to be the months and
the years after an agreement if there is
one that's reached because the history's
North Korea they'll deceive us so the
pageantry of an agreement is not as
important as North Korea actually doing
what they say does it happen
well it's interesting because the
president is very clear he wants to make
some kind of deal here right he has
driven in large part by being able to do
things his predecessors weren't able to
do he says that him
so if he's also you know invited
conversations about the Nobel Peace
Prize so I think I'm wondering kind of
how that plays into how North Korea is
thinking about this whether they can
exert leverage knowing that the
president wants this so badly percentage
Singapore June 12th yeah well I think
there will by I'd say 90 percent I think
that they'll meet because it's always in
this North Koreans interest to meet they
make an agreement that they don't
frequently abide by look I think Aries
right we have to keep our eye on the
ball
all right the ball here is not letting
them to get the capacity to strike the
United States with the nuclear missile
in a way it's Donald Trump's redline and
we're to where we are because he's been
tough and I think he should be tough and
I'm glad that John Bolton's there and
I'm I'm with John Bolton if we're going
to have a deal I'd rather Olivia type
deal than in Iran type deal all right
panel thank you very much